This is the Cal N.E.H. American English dialect recordings collection.
Tape number twenty four side B..
Oh
yeah
and
on
top of the new film.
Yet their brains were funny to me when I asked the because it
felt
fine to me when
I came out.
With come out there when he came out he said.
Do you
know
that it was the.
You doing service. We were not the mission.
Medium but it was slippery.
Your grandma. Everything has to do as you
say and
she almost fell into the god.
She lives in a garbage
get messy doing
the
bit that's going. Joy and joy I went in
there she was there and she
know what to do
everything.
And
then they were never the peace.
They're going to let their track.
We all call me.
OK.
As we have a Mickey Mouse.
Year.
To
now we raise a dollar for a
dollar because
nobody
but the truth. We're like a New York street.
But the people out here they don't want to have to
close with.
Our history over there
wanted for all.
You know.
He
will. But we all tell
me what are you doing you're making.
We have a Mickey
Mouse any. And I
will know
my man time give me
some data give me
the perennial mining town crime D.N.A. We know
we get no money and then in some moment we may move
is.
To
lay low we have to really get you Mary call you haven't really got
a story for one L.T.R. do we
want to relay cars.
We need to mask
get replay and they do already here. We've
been trying to make up the train they get Mickey Mouse the Regency had
a
reason. All right. It is really
good to be in in.
There is nice to be there. People
put me
in the could be alive so tear were marked down. You can
put a couple of dollars and a hill my dance group of
people like now
she
could
take their credit. She
were
all there when you go. I always put a mark
to cook
with people. Because they're about ours not
as fortunate as we are they either had a talk
in German town in Germany.
I planted back and or her
account to say. Good. You were.
THE GIRL.
I
knew.
Oh no she gave me a fridge
a million.
Well
beyond what do you have any.
Me too I have.
I get more
dollars. She gets
Oh yeah. Baby.
Worthy
they
really well.
You just plain
dumb ass again.
Some of them. Made
that hard.
The three.
I Bobby Dollar head. I get to is a Barbie doll here.
Play and then song and I
guess I got a puppet for Christmas.
And I got an outfit
from.
A rag
at home. A
J A.
Get in some clothes for my birthday. What do y'all do in the afternoons with your
dog don't play my dove down that you do is to
the Hill. Yeah me too that the only way ever I got there they all.
That's why I got a head don't mean either
hey here. There's even a way to break got to hear.
Jimmy ask women here. The moment. She
tell me to do that no do me
to. My mama tell me to do. Elissa Hill
and sure
enough. Because she really than all
the big O's but came out to play
and she.
In here. So she failed to get
into a hell she
get rid of
the game. Play she don't
girl Haleigh is long and it was my
mom could. You know mom. Do you have any
baby brother or sister. I guess think
children are
you in this hole.
Are
you who you know.
Before I get my good old Izzy bar next
to the old. Oh dear oh dear
no he. Might
go in the occur a
different route into a clue. Is only three over.
So
yes.
She's got sure
you
know I know. I know you know
Messina made my day to just kill my mom
because see. Matt did he
say he really did want to marry her.
He said it how people wanted to hear him to marry my mom.
So he said Mama sort of put the gun
on him a ARE hell but to marry your mom
or to make you mad
but when he gets to make all
these useful. DAISY.
Mama talk about his the baby. But she
says
great she's
right. We only have even heard of
a
few days where
you
come up to you Do you have to just be there you would be ample and we'd
go home. Well we had no fun
though and it's a hard day at it all
my mama didn't know
how Mom
lives. Oh in
the
bill as the goal would and I want
to leave Indians in the moment to call my mom and Jenna.
She were my clothes. We go to church together. Yeah I join her.
Church is she going
to have to go because you know
we
rally what we would to we were
right as you went to an egg farm to leave up egg farm what you do
after you. Oh no we're going
to take we take is and that that
is gone but because night it was just going as a nail go
across an amateur videotape.
And
then after a and then because we're down way to the three in
one cage when they are deep in the Indian immigrants.
And one of it was a big one dead saying all sexy and
then they are now ready
to yes and I reigned there.
And then the adult was there. So we went to see
the
adults and made a duck in there than we were
almost get the pit panda the
self-will karma ran around him in the way
for and email come back out and I am
a little brutal adult Bill to you
about this whole and if you see this amount
of kill me.
I want to live it.
I know you don't where you went in a war widow
with you had to go with you if you go in the
car. Work out I'll get
back. To
have these old where he is old
to have his own pay
as his
pale shadow Home
to have to
pay was
cloned and they do it now
they put him on
my own.
He may have he have a
head
down here.
And I brought him a blue bone with his bull like you get them
for his water. And he get
there
we go. I doubt they
named
me. Grandpa.
He'll bite me like you
don't play with.
The kind.
I'm
going
to.
By
blinking.
Our ways fall in the
video pull it
down to around and now.
We chase.
Because I use. The retina because ISIS
throw a little ball but it is still.
A
couple and.
There. He
is
gone
and the red light.
On her
ass very real.
I
mean.
This is not man. Oh oh.
Oh it's not her grandpa he gonna give me one.
Well that's a nice you have one on
you know. We
cover. You
know she you know she want me to do you know she.
You know we
mean that's the way you'll meet me.
My good to doing what I do through the
wind and the wind to back this
high.
I don't get a name gotta get
there and I run in the last
it through smokers just small fry up in
the grain essay calls on a job
in the budget was a mixed message and he
got him a girl free at the last week you know
or so and I feel plays because I
mean
like
yeah well.
Who. Look OK. Yeah.